I understand that you operate the alternative cancer treatment clinic in St. Paul.
What are the most common therapies or treatments that you offer?
Well, most people seek us out because of our work with
RIFE frequency technology, RIS. Okay. So that's uh...
You'll have to explain that. So that is an instrument that was developed
back in the 1930s and 40s by a man named Royal Raymond RIFE who you know
bears his name using the light frequencies
to help kill pathogens and he did a lot of his work on helping kill
cancer cells. Is that a similar kind of technology to like I'm
vaguely familiar with certain water treatments or water filtration treatments
using a certain light? Is that the same thing or completely different?
That's completely different. So like water treatment would be like using
hose odor or something like that or it'll
provide light to help kill pathogens in the water.
RIFE frequency is a light frequency. It's a Tesla tube
and it is you can program it with the different machines that are out there
based upon whatever frequency you want to run on the machine. So
from a basically simplest terms from a quantum physics perspective,
everything that exists is energy that's vibrating in a specific frequency.
So cells are vibrating in a specific frequency. Cancer cells are vibrating in a
specific frequency. If you could hit that cancer cell at its own
frequency, multiple positive events could happen.
So RIFE believed if you hit the cancer cell in its own frequency, you cause cell
lysis, which is cell death. Lysis is what's called a pathological death of a cell.
That's what happens typically with chemotherapy is cell lysis.
I don't necessarily believe that cell lysis actually occurs with RIFE
or we would get ill effects like detox reactions and such
that you get with chemotherapy. But I do believe that it stimulates a
poptosis. I do believe it stimulates an immune system
reactionator. You hit with its old frequencies. It's going to cause that thing
to vibrate and that's going to help the immune system, your T cells,
your macrophages to recognize that as an enemy because that's one of the
problems with cancer is it is your own cells. It's not an
enemy like a bacteria. It's your own cell. That's in a
rapid replication phase. And your immune system is
created to not attack self tissue. That would be called an auto immune disease.
So your immune system is created to leave cancer cells alone,
your own tissue cells alone. So if you can stimulate an immune response
to the cancer, you can help your body kill the
cancer. And that's really how I believe RIFE works. There's about 20 to
five different theories. If you read some
in-depth quantum physics, energy medicine books, there's numerous out there on
the market. You get into detail theories on how it actually works.
But I think in a simplest form, you're stimulating an immune response to help
your body attack the cancer. And that requires an immune response. So you have
to have a healthy immune response. And that's where
using other things to stimulate an immune healthy immune response like
a nutraceuticals and essential oils and stuff is essential
to go along with the RIFE in order for it to work
and it's best.